mr. president thank you for joining us
we're here at the third annual CGI
America you're working with business and
political leaders to find ways to create
economic growth right now
what's a commitment that you're really
excited about that you've had happen
here we had this year a new commitment
from the number of Native American
tribes to join together to pool their
resources to generate electricity from
when treated into the grid and earn
money for the tribes the reason this is
important to me is that most people
don't know it but the poorest Americans
are still Native Americans who live on
tribal lands without access to casinos
and all of those at least west of the
Mississippi have enormous capacity to
generate solar and wind energy but they
haven't been able to organize themselves
so that they can guarantee a cash flow
stream that would enable them then to
build use the cash to invest in their
areas and diversify their economies so
this is really the first big commitment
we've had that I think has the promise
to help people that live on tribal lands
actually use their capacity to generate
in this case wind energy to diversify
their own economies and build a
different future for themselves I think
that's really important it's also
frankly a microcosm of a big problem in
America and other countries face which
is how to put an economic strategy in
place that will help very rural areas as
well as densely packed urban areas so
I'm excited about it I don't know what
will happen for sure but I mean I know
the windmills will put up and they'll
work and that'll work for fine but
whether this will be the beginning of a
different economic model I can't say but
I hope it will be because that's one of
things we try to do I'm excited about
the st. Bernard project which is going
to put up a housing that will be more
resist
to tornadoes and hurricanes and floods
and Queens in New York in Joplin
Missouri and in New Orleans as a model
housing because there's going to be a
huge movement in the years ahead
I think driven by insurance companies
primarily for us to build rebuild and
remodel all of our structures to make
them more resilient Mayor Bloomberg you
may have seen proposed I think a 19 and
a half billion dollar plan just to make
New York better able to resist the
destructive impacts of rising sea waters
over the next 30 years so I'm excited
about that because I think most people
need models they can say I could do that
I can afford that we can manage this so
I think that's a very good thing to well
you mentioned wind energy just moments
ago I hosted a panel on energy we talked
a lot about all the alternatives out
there right now and the importance of it
in terms of weaning ourselves off oil
and what it means for our relationship
with the Middle East what are your
thoughts on Syria right now and given
the news of chemical weapons that we
just learned about do you think that we
need to be involved there what would you
advise well we have been if we've been
supporting the rebels in various ways
and intelligence to know other ways and
the White House announced today that
they because of the chemical weapons
discovery and I think because of the
more overt and aggressive involvement of
Iran and they're the troops they support
from Hezbollah mostly coming out of
Lebanon that they're going to do more
and I think that it's not clear yet
exactly who will do what partly because
the president wants to talk to the other
people in the g8 about it which i think
is a good thing and they're going to
meet in the next few days in Ireland and
also because the logistics of getting
weapons into the area are somewhat
complicated and
risky so for example if they decide to
take them in through Jordan they've got
to secure the site the Jordanians are
already vulnerable enough because they
have hundreds of thousands of Syrian
refugees there but I think on balance
that's the right thing to do I don't
think that we should send troops there
but I don't think we should stay where
we are I think we should do more because
when you say do more well I think the
general Idris asks for very specific set
of weapons and the United States
supports him it's one of the rebel
leaders we have supported and feel good
about and the administration announced
they were going to send more weapons
today so I don't know enough about the
details to go beyond that except I think
that if you look at what's going on
you've got Iran trying to dominate the
region you've got Iran trying to inflame
the Sunni Shia rift instead of trying to
work out arrangements where it can be
managed and you've got this internal
conflict in Syria which may make it like
Lebanon was in the 1970s for an
unlimited period of time and then and it
destabilizes Lebanon when the Lebanese
that those of us are old enough to
remember how Lebanon was all torn up in
the 70s when they resolved it they they
have a constitution in Lebanon and I
think we ought to talk about it
because one of the things that we're all
concerned about in the Arab Spring is
that okay we get an election and the
people with the most votes win and then
nothing else about democracy is
guaranteed elections are more than
majority rule it's minority rights
shared decision-making protection of
individual rights the rule of law takes
sometimes a very long time to get that
took us a long time it took us a long
time to eliminate slavery a long time to
give women the vote a long time to get
rid of the last vestiges of racial
discrimination but in the modern world
the only way to short-circuit is
if you live in a conflict society like
Lebanon Syria or Iraq is to ensure that
everybody can participate in government
so in the Lebanese system you typically
have a sunni Prime Minister a Shias
Speaker of the legislature and a
Christian president and there you know
you have the Maronites you have the
grooves you have the Cena the Shia and
the Sunni and and Kurds a big Kurdish
population in Syria so we don't think we
can afford not to at least be on the
side of the angels here that we want all
these people to be treated right and we
want an intuitive government that has
been responsible now for about ninety
thousand deaths so I think that I feel
good about the announcement and I think
we should wait and see what the details
are you all will get it all you'll
figure it out but the administration is
right to be a little circumspect about
how they're going to get these weapons
in and what they're going to do